so hello everyone my name is Mark
passing I'm a developer advocate here at
Google
I'm member of the media team so I'm
usually working with large media
partners audio and video partners to
improve the streaming experience of
their app so usually this boils down to
integrate exoplayer or to help them
migrate to exoplayer so let me start
with one of those mandatory instant
service just to cool down the speaker a
little bit to of you watched video on
YouTube in the last week on Android yeah
not surprisingly a very good number so
all of you who raised your hand you
already are exoplayer user because
exoplayer is the default video player in
the YouTube app so that's let me start
with the first slide with a website I
found some years ago or some months ago
on the internet it's obviously not a
Google website if a website from YouTube
uses theaters the YouTube exoplayer
guide and there were some users they
found that YouTube started using
exoplayer extra player within the
YouTube app and they found that
experience so exciting that they found
ways to kind of hack YouTube to force
YouTube to use X player all the time and
on all all devices so there is a very
nice quote on this website is quote says
exoplayer is an experimental video
player hidden inside Google's YouTube
app it loads videos much much faster but
made unavailable to the average person
so let me be clear most of this quote is
not true so X player is not at all
experimental X player is not hidden
inside the YouTube app and it's not
unavailable to the average person I may
agree to the thing in the parent is it
loads video much faster so that's the
improved video experience we want to
have from exo player so again that will
be cleared up not true it's available on
github you can download it on github
so what is exoplayer damage ex-player is
a so-called
application-level media player library
next application level media player
library means you can include the
library within your apk within your app
and ship it to your user with your apk
regarding the living room extra player
is a perfect choice all Android TV
devices support exoplayer Android TV
devices run on lollipop and grater so
all those devices support EXO player but
EXO play is not only a good choice for
TV it's also an excellent choice for
mobile all devices support which have a
TI 16 and greater support EXO player so
I have his number here 9 9 95.7 % this
is the share of Android devices running
API 16 and later so that's a quite good
number for all devices out there extra
player is built on some public API is
provided by the media framework so to
say this clearly explained does not use
some kind of hidden API soar private API
is only available for you for google
Tech except a really uses public API
it's the Android media media API on the
one hand and the Android media DRM API
on the other hand so at least in theory
you can write such a player for yourself
but as of course not a really easy task
that's why we released exoplayer some
years ago as an open source product on
Keita
so you can include it into your apps as
well
so what is such an application-level
mediaplayer I already mentioned you can
include this library in your apk and
ship it to your users as part of your
apk we see here this white box at the
top this white box is the apk which
contains an application that will media
player on in this case X player itself
and now this application level media
player or XO player uses those API is
available this diagram here is XO player
in an earlier version today it looks
little bit otherwise we will have a look
at this later we see those arrows XO
player is using the media extractor API
it's using the media codecs API and it's
using the audio track they try all of
those or public API is available for in
own Android when you have a little bit a
look at the grey boxes we have this
media extractor with those green boxes
in it so this is what a streaming video
player has to do here at first you have
to download contain the data from the
internet then we have to buffer this
data until we really need it and once we
need the data we need to instruct
extract audio and and video samples out
of the container when we have those
samples those audio and those video
samples they are still encoded so we
can't really render those so we need the
media codecs API to decode those samples
and once we have those samples in the
decoded way we can render those with
Android in a case of video we only have
to pass a surface to the codecs API and
the codecs API itself then does the
rendering on this surface in case of
audio files the result of tossing these
encoded frames is or PCM frames so PCM
trails which we then can play by using
the audio track so that's what is what
is involved in both in audio streaming
and in
you're streaming and there's still a
little bit a problem with this diagram
so all those tasks are kind of buried in
the in the api's in the api's of the
framework so if you want to customize or
you want to kind of change the behavior
recording those tasks there is no
nothing we can do because everything is
done by the framework which we can't
really customize exoplayer uses or early
versions of exoplayer used those
frameworks sample source class this
framework sample source costs used the
media extractor api to do this
networking buffering and extracting
tasks and that's what we also see in the
next slide little bit more focused but
still the frame examples can't really
influence what mediaextractor
is doing in detail and that's exactly
what we want so they explain in the end
decide to duplicate this framework
sample source and to do all these tasks
in exoplayer itself so the diagram which
we have seen before now looks like this
so all those green tufts are moved into
the EXA players are moved into the apk
and that's why we now can customize the
behavior of those tasks so if you want
for example to use another network stack
you can use another net a network stack
by using a custom data source you can
influence buffering and you can even
support other containers other video or
audio containers which are not supported
by the framework so by moving those
tasks into the realm of exoplayer itself
within some customizations that's
exactly what we want
regarding the other two media api's
there is not much we can win by
replacing them usually the media codecs
uses hardware backed functionality to
decode those frames and to do really an
efficient job and that's something we
never want to do in software so this
still is done by those media api's
provided by API by Android the same is
true for the audio track there is not
much
to play audio in an other way than with
an audio track
so why should you as a developer use EXO
play what are the advantages of using
exit play first of all there are those
streaming formats like - and smooth
streaming those two are not supported by
the media framework itself so if you
want to use - or smooth streaming you
need to use something else than the
media player the player of the framework
and of course what we recommend is using
HLS if using extra player so HLF is also
supported by EXO player and it's also
supported by media player in this case
if you already use HLS with the media
player and you are okay with that there
is nothing against using media player
but for reasons of for some reason we
all also support HLS with explain
another advantage is as I already said
you can include ex player as a greater
dependency within Europe and you can
ship ex player or this library with your
apk - you use the biggest advantage of
this is that you are really sure that
every user is using the very same
version of your player that's been very
interesting feature because if if you
are using the media framework and one
user has an older device he will use
another player version than user with a
newer device and if you have to debug
problems or so you always have to make
sure that you are testing the very same
version with EXO player that's kind of
easy because you can say which version
you ship with your apk besides this
ability of using the very same version
you also can take advantage of the
faster release cycle of exoplayer ex
player sometimes releases new versions
within months and you know with Android
devices that's something a little bit
different some devices are updated very
rarely so if you have to wait for a bug
fix for a framework components for some
devices unit will never get these
updates so with EXO player you can just
include the new version of the library
in your apk and ship it to your users
and in the end the most interesting
features for some developers is the
ability to customize
exoplayer that's exactly what we have
seen in the diagram before by moving
those tasks of networking buffering and
extracting data from the containers we
gain some customization some means to
customization those thoughts and that's
exactly what we want if we have some
specific requirements to meet within
your apps
for Android TV of course ex-player is a
very good choice if you want to support
4k exoplayer is ready for 4k so if you
have 4k content which you want to bring
to you use of extra player it's a very
good choice
x-play also is ready for some very
modern audio codecs like Dolby Digital
for example if you have connected your
Nexus player for example to to a TV
which supports total beat each two extra
player can recognize this if the TV
advertises support for those codecs by
HDMI and then expert will just pass
through the encoded encoded audio data
to the TV and the TV will do the
decoding and the playback of those
modern audio codecs one of the
customizations which we see very often
on Android TV is that you can customize
the bitrate algorithm the bitrate
adoption algorithm you know the android
framework is still made for optimized
for mobile so if the media player starts
playback starts doing adaptive playback
it starts with the lowest video quality
if you are on a mobile network that
makes perfectly sense because you want
you start playback as soon as soon as
possible so the media player starts with
the lowest quality on Android TV that's
little bit different all Android TV
usually are connected by Wi-Fi to the
internet or even by Ethernet so you have
good bandwidth and so you may want to
start not with the lowest or maybe miss
a medium video quality to have a very
good quality for you users very quickly
so if you want to customize this bit
right our detection algorithm exoplayer
is a good choice and in the end an expla
is also ready for content protection and
receive it was not only support Widevine
it also supports play ready and with
extra player you can use white one or
play ready for both for - and
moves really in fact exoplayer supports
common encryption which includes support
for those wide for those products
available on android TV
a question which comes up very quickly
when I talk to my partner so we are
which media formats are supported by
exoplayer that's not really an easy
question so let's start with the first
row of this table let thought with
streaming formats I already said it's -
and smooth streaming and HLS these are
the streaming formats which are
supported by exoplayer while HLS is also
supported by the media framework only
exoplayer supports - and smooth
streaming container formats are very
strength of exoplayer we have seen that
we move those green boxes into the
application space so exoplayer does
extracting data out of these containers
itself
this means exoplayer can support
arbitrary containers and it can support
more containers than the framework does
so we have here a couple of common
container formats that there is empty
for of course days WebM matroska which
is supported by a pro player there are a
couple of audio containers like mp3 ogg
and wave and then there are the HLS
container formats and pac tears and pac
PS and a DTS
when it comes to video and audio formats
extra player can do this itself the
decoding of those video formats and
audio forms it's just delegated to the
media framework so exoplayer supports
all those formats which are supported by
the media framework there is web page on
developer.android.com which you can
consult to see what media frame what
video and audio formats are supported
another important type of formats or
closed captions and subtitles for
professional media companies this is a
very important feature they have to
provide sometimes by for legal reasons
closed captions and subtitles so that's
very important extra player supports
TTML and web vtg for - and smooth
streaming these are the most common
formats for - smooth streaming and it
supports 608 for HLS the format which
usually is used it with HLS
another question which comes up very
quickly so if I have to put this player
library into my apk my apk will get
bigger and some developers are afraid of
maybe hitting the Dex limit you know
there was some a certain amount of
methods which you can include in your
text file so that's a very important
question how many methods are included
with the exoplayer library the numbers
which we have here it's the kitchen sink
library so it's the very highest number
you can get if you Pro got your apk
usually ProGuard is able to remove a lot
of those methods so because usually you
don't use HLS - and Smooth Streaming in
one apk you use only one of those
streaming formats and so ex-pro god is
able to remove many of these mode
methods after I did a audio application
little audio application and then Probot
removed about 2000 of those methods I
ended up with having about 900 methods
for an audio playback application who is
using exoplayer already also very
important question you don't want to
beat a test Google software if your uses
of course you want to have well tested
software in your apk so Google itself
uses ex-player in their most famous
application YouTube I already mentioned
is using exoplayer there's also Google
Play Movies
which is using extra player on mobile
and on Android devices and the next last
Google application is Google Fiber which
also relies on exoplayer for doing video
playback I already mentioned I'm working
with large media partners and there are
a couple of large media partners which
also use exoplayer internally we usually
do not expose these partners so what I
can assure you there are really large
companies using exoplayer like Google
does
yeah hopefully soon you will use
exoplayer too if I'm a little bit
convincing today you will download
exoplayer and once you downloaded
exoplayer I'm pretty sure you will like
it and soon you will include it in your
apk as well so let's have a look at some
basic use cases and for a media player
of course basic use cases is playing
audio and video files so what do you
have to do to play audio or video files
with explain the third thing is of
course including explain in your apk the
easiest thing to do this is just add
another Gradle dependency to your Gradle
files and then x-play will be included
and you can use all those clauses away
when you're using exoplayer yes x-play
has the concept of track renders you
need a track render for every type of
data you want to render usually you have
audio audio data video data and text
data namely subtitles or closed captions
so in a full-fledged video application
you have three track renders for this
use case of using of doing all your
playback there is only one track render
needed and that's exactly what we see in
this highlighted code snippet here we
are real we require such a track render
in this case it's media codec audio
track render so the interface is a track
render and the concrete cloth
implementing this interface is a media
codec audio track track this media codec
audio track render now takes a couple of
arguments in its constructor and the
most important one is the first or the
most interesting one is the first
argument the sample source the sample
source is a collaborating component so
the media codec audio track render
requires a sample source to get audio
data or audio samples from it that's
exactly what we see now in the next line
of code here we are creating such
instance of a sample source again we
have the sample source which is only
Java interface the concrete
implementation then is an extractor
sample source and extract a sample
source is provided by the exoplayer
library here again a couple of arguments
in the constructor the second
constructor is of interest here the data
source the data source is again another
collaborator which then is created in
the line above again we have a data
source interface a Java interface data
source which is then provided as a
default URI data source now with the
very same pattern again the date of
default URI data source needs a
bandwidth meter and again this bandwidth
meter a concrete implementation of
bandwidth meter is provided by the exit
player library so we're kind of wire up
a chain of components are each depending
on another component and it's kind of
obvious that it's quite a kind of easy
to create your own implementation of one
of those compose interfaces if you have
such a custom implementation of such an
interface you can just instantiate it
and inject it into the constructor of
the other components those arrays
highlight this pattern little bit so we
create one component and inject it into
the other component to get a chain of
those components so once we have this
audio renderer or this track rendered
for audio we need to kind of register
those renders in the exoplayer itself so
we create area of track renders assign
the audio renders to one of the position
of those of this array and then we pass
it to the own renders method
so this was what we need to do for doing
all your playback for video playback as
already said we have some other type of
data there is not only only audio there
is also video data and eventually you
want to render text subtitles or club or
closed captions as well so again we need
three of those chains of dependent
components so we need a tractor under
the tractor and Rodan needs a sample
source each sample source again needs a
data source which in the end needs a
bandwidth meter if you want to do
adaptive adaptive playback so let me be
clear again you don't have to provide
your own implementation each component
has a default implementation provided by
the exoplayer library you can kind of
wire up your renders as you want so
there is no need to really implement
these things if you don't have specific
requirements you can just use it as the
demo application does demonstrate
besides these track renderer components
there are a couple of UI components
available as well so these components
are not really mandatory but they are
very convenient to use there is for
example this aspect ratio frame layout
it's a layout which make sure that the
surface view on which the video is
rendered is always resized nicely so if
a user for example changes the
orientation of a mobile device you have
to resize the surface view too to match
the size of the of the viewport another
another component is at the very bottom
it's the subtitle layout again this
subtitle layer is in the end optional to
use but if you want to render text or
closed captions or subtitles it's very
convenient to use it's the same size as
the entire layout or the surface few
hairs and it's kind of a a layer above
the video on which exoplayer can render
those subtitles
so there's a lot of going on we have
seen that you have to download download
data we have to buffer data we have to
extract data out of the containers and
in the end we have to render this data
to a surface or to the audio track so
there is a lot of lot is going on in
this video player in you if you want to
be aware of what is going on you can
implement some listeners and then
register those listeners so on a high
level there is the extra player top
listener this is a listener which
notifies you about the high level state
of the player so when you start the
player is in an idle state and that it
transitions to a buffering stage so we
have to start downloading data and as
soon as there is enough data we can
start playback if you want to give some
signals to your user are now the player
is buffering there is not enough data
available you can just implement such a
listener and listen to those state
transitions
besides this high level without it high
level events there are a couple of low
level events so there are many of those
components which you have to wire up and
each of those components has an event
listener so we see here that the demo
player this snippet again is out of the
exoplayer Pro check it is from the it's
from the demo player application of
exoplayer it implements each four it
implements an event listener for each of
those components so whatever is going on
in one of those components your
application is aware of what is going on
and you can act upon this transition
these stage twenty transitions
so
let's have a look at the architecture or
design we now have seen that there are
many such components which are dependent
on each other so let's have a look at
the diagram this is a diagram of the
component model or the object model
which is required to do traditional
media playback traditional media
playback is is not it so called non
adaptive playback so there is one single
container file sitting on a server on
the internet somewhere and we need to
download this container and then we need
to extract data out of this container
that's exactly what what we need for
such for such traditional media playback
is again we need to tract render we have
these blue boxes on the right this is a
media codec video track render and the
media codec audio track render those two
are responsible to kind of render audio
and video track video data by using the
public media APs each of those track
renders is now dependent or on an
extractor sample source these extract of
sample source uses an extractor in this
case it's an mp4 extractor which knows
how to extract audio and video data out
of this mp4 container then passes the
sample to the extractor sample source
which again causes it to the tract
renders for rendering so if you want to
support some kind of a custom container
format maybe you invented a super
efficient container format for video you
can just create your own extractor
register this rec tractor extractor with
the extractor sample source and then you
can support this new kind of container
maybe you have some kind of content
protection in built into the container
if you have such in invented such
container you can also kind of plug-in
these container formats with X player
and in the end at the very left we see
the default URI data source again this
is an implement
creation of the data source the
extractor sample source relied on and if
you want to for example support
proprietary Network protocol you can
implement your own data source here to
support those protocols
so the next diagram shows the same
object model for adaptive media play the
difference here is that we did the video
player has to pick the quality of the
video chunks so again on the very right
we have those blue boxes if the media
contact video track render and the audio
track render which does the rendering at
the end those two now are dependent on
chunks samples and chunks of the source
itself depends on it
- chunk source the - chunk source is now
the component which knows the manifest
of - so in the manifest there are
references to video chunks of different
quality and as soon as we know that we
have good bandwidth good network
bandwidth exoplayer should pick a better
quality over a lower quality the - chunk
source then again relies on a data
source to actually do the downloading
again you can replace these components
if you want the most important thing
here now is the adaptive evaluate the
adapt evaluator does some metering of
the network speed so as soon as he
usually we start with a low quality or
in case of android TV we start with
maybe a medium quality of those chunks
and the adaptive evaluator does meet the
bandwidth of the network as soon as we
start downloading data I already
mentioned that this bitrate adoption
algorithm might be one candidate you
want to customize and if you want you
you can only replace this tiny component
of the adaptive our way to not store
with the lowest quality but maybe with a
medium quality and then replace this
component when you wire up those object
this object model so you really have
just to replace this tiny piece of this
object model create provide your custom
implementation and then in the end they
work together nicely with the default
component
delivered by the exoplayer library
so yeah you may say yeah but that's a
really a complex thing to wire up all
these components right if I use media
player just have two lines of code and
it starts playback and yeah that's true
this flexibility or this ability to
customize things comes with a price of
this added complexity but the good news
is an extra player provides some
templates to wire up these objects
together there are templates for -
smooth streaming and HLS for example and
we have for example the - Randall
Builder which does wire up the component
model for doing - streaming usually you
don't have to change these templates you
can just use it as it's provided by the
exoplayer library if you have some
specific requirements you have some
specific features within your - manifest
for example maybe you have to adapt what
the - render builder is doing but again
you are it's a very good start to look
into these renderer builders these
renderer builders again are part of the
demo application so if you download the
project and you have a look at the demo
application you will find these render
builders and can't start from there
the last render builder which is
available is the known adopt for non
adaptive playback it's again for
traditional media playback and it's
pretty much the same it's not that
complicated we have seen the diagram
there are less components which work
together but if you want to do
traditional playback again you can start
with this extractor render builder
so yeah now call to action so of course
we have some call to actions for you so
clone the exoplayer project it's
available on github easiest thing is
just to search for key top and exoplayer
and you will find repository clone the
repository build the APK and deploy the
APK the demo application to your android
device and then start testing the demo
application includes a list of sample
streams there are sample streams for -
smooth streaming HLS there are some
streams for the different content
protection technologies this like white
wine and PlayReady and check it out and
if you find your streams you want to
support it's quite easy to start from
the demo application and in the end of
course integrate exoplayer as a library
into your own app take the demo
application as a template and then use
exoplayer by integrating it with a
cradle dependency there are other ways
to do that you can copy the source code
into your apk or you can build a library
and then put the library in your IDE but
the easiest way is just use a great
depends
so that's basically what I have so there
are again those links to the exoplayer
project itself and there is also
reference to the developer guide
developer guides gives you in-depth
information about customizing exoplayer
for your needs all those diagrams we've
seen in this talk are taken from the
developer guide so it's a pretty good
read for you if you want to meet your
requirements to check out exoplayer the
exoplayer developer gasps yeah that's
all I have so if you have some questions
please go to the microphone and all
questions so everybody can hear it and
I'm happy to answer these questions
excuse me
360 videos now expired currently does
not support I think that YouTube has a
YouTube has a kind of a modified version
but currently no support for 360 excuse
me okay
I don't sorry yeah currently no support
from explains there is not the public
road map we are there is on github there
are different branches we are that we
have the productive branch then there is
the development branch if you look into
development branch you look a little bit
into the future
there is also currently an experimental
branch we are working currently on
version 2 of exoplayer which brings in
some more flexibility especially at run
time so the all those components will be
about the same but at runtime we have
more more ways to kind of replace
components at runtime so but there is
not something like a public road map
available if you are interested in
feature I can just go to the except to
the issue tracker of github and the team
is there and will answer about your
other plans of the team
while a Chili's is supported post media
player and Express HLS is supported
possible mega player yeah I don't know
actually so I mean ageless is a very
popular format and then it was included
into the into the framework itself media
player supports HLS and then as soon as
we start with X to play I mean it makes
sense to support all those most commonly
use adaptive formats so yeah which one
is better yeah mmm it depends so you can
try your streams if you are okay with
what main media player can do it's okay
if you want to customize the behavior
that's in the end the thing if you want
to adjust the player to your
requirements in yep I would recommend to
use exoplayer but I mean if one of those
works for you both for okay so there is
no reason to use one over the other
yeah exactly I don't know I don't know
about the internals of YouTube
application sorry
I'm like thanks for the presentation so
from our experience when we used extra
player some of the lower end phones our
experience is that sometimes the video
stutters sometimes the video doesn't
play at all like do you have any
recommendations how we can figure out if
a phone support section of a year or not
it's hard to say what the reason is
because I already said so
especially when is when it comes to
decoding exoplayer is using the
framework classes or the framework api
as well so if there and those ATS
usually are provided by the vendor by
the OEM which provides the device so
they are there are different
implementation on each of those devices
and if there is a problem on certain
device it may be that it's just on this
device and it's very hard to say in
channel what the problem is on low yeah
on these devices maybe yeah maybe I
would recommend to create a power report
after you experience this problem and to
to set this bug report into an issue on
github and ask the exoplayer team if
they know about a common issue with
these devices from my understanding here
you are saying that the YouTube app is
using extra player by default do you
know how to handle it now sorry I don't
know about internals of YouTube app okay
thank you welcome one quick question on
the video when would you run during
implementation do you have plans to
support sidebar and totally support what
side band you know in each side band
no I don't I don't know about it but
maybe we can talk offline about it and
then I can ask the team yeah I guess one
question that the exoplayer does the
exoplayer have the capability to extract
metadata from the video and display from
what to what format let's see if your
video source has some metadata or
building to it like a big four-part 10
you have on the packet headers you can
put metadata on that does the exoplayer
have the framework to extract that
metadata and overlay it on the video
good question I don't know for and
before I know for example for HLS we are
extracting the id3 tags and then you are
able to kind of get the information
companies tagged yeah that's different
from the closed caption that that
particular yeah yeah yeah it's this I
mean we looked at the developer guide
that I didn't see any references to the
metadata yeah I'm not sure maybe I'll
let us check offline and tell me I can
help you maybe DRM DRM yeah this is all
right yeah yeah yeah
it depends on what what adaptive
technology you are using if you are
using HLS AAS 128 is supported and for -
and for smooth streaming we support
common encryption so for example
Widevine and PlayReady on android TV on
our white wine or mobile devices Oh am i
sorry oh ma oh ma I don't know so in
general if you really want to have very
good security you have to support you
have to use one of those DRM
technologies which are available on the
devices because they need the keys to be
in the hardware and so I think the
really if you want to really secure
solution you have to use white wine or
play ready
our TV can be you exoplayer on android
TV to the crm contain yeah sure yeah
sure you can use white wine and
PlayReady on android TV thank you
so maybe the last question yep yeah hi
so I have a question on how do you
detect cloned Android devices from the
perspective of the exoplayer also can
you say something about the ad insertion
capabilities yeah so there is nothing
specifically for at insertion currently
in exoplayer so we have partners which
duties for themselves so you have to
kind of that's exactly one of the fields
which you which explains very good at
you can replace one of those components
and do the adding searching itself but
there is nothing provided out of the box
what about the clone devices is there a
way to detect what what device is sorry
cloned let's say I have a clone in sense
of a valid like a virtual instance of a
valid and Android install and I'm
running that from the exoplayer I'm
running the same exoplayer same content
or is there a way to detect whether a
device is a clone device or a real
device yeah not built in into exoplayer
this you have to do this for yourself as
well yeah thanks thank you so thank you
very much for your attention